vamos a hablar de salud aquí en directo
américa france24 más romero sala me
acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo del
jueves mar vamos a empezar en colombia
el primer país de américa latina que ha
legalizado el subsidio médicamente
asistido así es raúl en muy buen jueves
empezamos con este tema es una demanda
que interpuso el laboratorio de derechos
económicos sociales y culturales
laboratorio deslave ante la corte
constitucional que finalmente se
pronunció ayer por la tarde con seis
votos a favor y tres en contra
escuchemos el mensaje de la parte que
interpuso la demanda
se trata de un nuevo mecanismo que junto
con la eutanasia nos permitirá acceder a
una muerte médicamente asistida a una
muerte libre o una muerte segura o una
muerte acompañada la corte y la sociedad
colombiana han dado un paso en la
dirección correcta y han ampliado y
profundizado el derecho fundamental a
morir dignamente
recordemos que colombia ya había
legalizado la otan asia de hecho en 1997
aunque nos había puesto en práctica
hasta una década después la diferencia
con la eutanasia en este caso es que el
suicidio médico asistido en estos casos
es el médico el profesional de la salud
que administra el medicamento la droga
que sirva pues para terminar
voluntariamente con la vida de una
persona mientras que en la eutanasia es
la propia persona que lo decide está
vivo de hecho en este país el debate
recientemente porque se aprobó la
eutanasia para dos personas que no eran
enfermas terminales que no iban a morir
en el corto plazo pero que sin embargo
se consideraba que el dolor y el
sufrimiento que comportaban sus
enfermedades crónicas pues no hacían que
la vida o no consideraban que al final
pues de esa vida mereciera ser vivida
porque al final es allí donde nos lleva
este debate queremos vivir que vidas son
dignas como vivimos una vida que merezca
la pena pero también como queremos morir
de qué manera es morir dignamente o de
qué manera no y la verdad es que hace
falta reconocer y recordar que muy pocos
países que tienen este debate resuelto
colombia es uno de los pocos del puñado
de países como españa canadá también que
tienen legalizadas estas prácticas y
como decías es de lo único en américa
latina' así es mar pasamos ahora a
hablar de eeuu porque ese país registró
su récord de muertes por sobredosis en
el año 2021 pues así son cálculos de los
centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu en base al registro
real de muertes más unas estimaciones
para llenar algunos vacíos de
información son resultados provisionales
de alertan que podrían además pues
crecer todavía en los próximos meses
estamos hablando de 107 mil
622 muertes en 2021 por sobredosis
repasemos estas cifras que suponen
además un aumento del 15 por ciento
respecto a las cifras del 2020 un
aumento por cierto de este 15 por ciento
que se suma al del 30 por ciento del año
anterior 2020 y que nos habla mucho de
la crisis también que ha supuesto la
pandemia en respecto al consumo de
drogas ya su relación con la salud
también importante destacar que dos de
cada tres muertes dos tercios de estas
muertes fueron por los opioides
sintéticos una crisis raúl que
recordemos que en eeuu de hecho supone
una verdadera epidemia hablamos de
medicamentos por ejemplo como el
fentanilo que se prescriben contra el
dolor pero que son altamente adictivos y
que para muchos pues se recitaron y se
publicitaron de manera irresponsable sin
advertir de esta capacidad de adicción y
que abrieron la puerta a adicción a
otras drogas a millones de personas en
eeuu varias farmacéuticas actualmente
están en juicios algunos han terminado
en pagos millonarios como compensación y
entre ellos es también importante
recordar que está la farmacéutica
johnson johnson así es marc y terminamos
esta crónica de salud del día de hoy 12
de mayo porque es el que mémora el día
mundial de la enfermería si vamos a
dedicar este último espacio a esto muy
importante también en tiempos de
pandemia no al final donde los
trabajadores sanitarios y sobre todo el
personal de enfermería han sido esa
primera línea en contra del cobi 19 y
que nos dan cuidado todos este era el
mensaje de la organización panamericana
de la salud
el personal de enfermería es la columna
vertebral de los sistemas de salud
dependemos de ellas y ellos para dar
atención primaria apoyo en salud mental
y para proteger el bienestar de los
individuos las comunidades y las
familias son munitis de alterar mis
buenas
expectativas del personal de enfermería
enfrenta dificultades en su trabajo todo
el sistema de salud sufre sobre roger
need para cubrir nuestras necesidades la
ope s estima que la región de las
américas necesitará 1,8 millones de
enfermeros más para 2030
esa es una de las conclusiones
principales que queremos destacar el día
de hoy falta personal si revisamos las
cifras que hay por ejemplo en américa
latina vemos que los únicos países que
superan la proporción recomendada entre
enfermeras y población son eeuu y chile
cuba y brasil se acercan pero es que
luego hay países como argentina perú
méxico están muy lejos de esta cifra
recomendada y pues no hablar de algunos
de los países de américa central o de
haití donde es altamente insuficiente ha
sido uno de los y reclamos de esta
pandemia contratar más personal médico y
sobre todo más personal de enfermería
mejorar sus condiciones laborales y
dignificar un trabajo que además en
total los enfermeros representan el 56
por ciento de todo el personal sanitario
en el continente americano y el 89 por
ciento además son mujeres una profesión
altamente feminizado que de hecho pues
eso puede contribuir a cierta
discriminación contra esta enfermedad
que se considera contra esta enfermedad
perdón contra esta profesión que se
considera inferior por ejemplo al de los
médicos al de otros profesionales y
cuando ellas muchas veces son las
personas que realmente dan ese primer
contacto con el paciente y cuidan y
apoyan de una manera que queda
invisibilizada pero que es igual de
importante pues que al final saber qué
medicamento darte mar pues muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información de salud de este día jueves
nos vemos mañana con más información
pasamos a saludar a nuestra segunda
mitad del día